e
subcommittee
um so just uh for uh committee committee
information as we go forward here um we
have 13 bills we're executing
tomorrow and and we will be uh if
anybody wants I will be sending out my
cheat sheet I am I'm looking for some
sponsors for motions and so uh looking
we'll have that conversation um in terms
of uh what going forward we um Tuesday
is uh town meeting day so we will not be
meeting on town meeting day so that
means that Wednesday the
14th that um the the remaining 26 bills
in the committee that um U some of them
we've actually acted on but some of but
um vast majority we have we will have
subcommittees on all everything on that
day so do not you know be warned that's
a good day to be here okay and then the
following week um the the Tuesday the
18th um we we I would be scheduling any
more subcommittees or bills from that
that first day that still need to be be
continued to be processed and then uh
[Music]
12th
okay yeah I know
I'm so what day is town meeting
day okay all right so I was I was off by
a
day uh okay
sorry all right so terms of um next
week the 11th which is town meeting day
we will not meet at
all the
12th we will have I will be scheduling
subcommittees for all remaining bills
that have not had their subcommittees
and everything so so there and in my to
my account there's 23 of them 26 of them
or something okay and then 13th is a
session
day and then the following week the 18th
Tuesday the
18th um I will be scheduling whatever
whatever whatever doesn't get done when
we at on the 12th whatever is left over
that needs an extra subcommittee or
not and then so Wednesday the 19th we'll
bills
okay and I'll I'll yeah I'll review this
again tomorrow when we have our exact
session but I just want because you guys
are here we get to know
firsthand
bill all right I just I just trying to
make sure
there
okay speak now for Hold Your Pie okay um
I I I'm sure that the
the motives were very well intent to try
to you know address this issue I have to
say is um for myself personally who now
just
officially um now joined the infamous
health insurance company uh because
I that's why he's hiding in the back of
room so but uh so I I I found it very
enlightening in terms of the the issues
that are out there with the two
different kind of Medicare products and
so in that in that sense I'm glad the
sponsor put it in so i' I've learned a
lot and and and feel much more informed
um but at the end of the day
um I did not see a solution so
representa SP would you like to also uh
you want to we could start up with
discussion yes I spent a week studying
this and having been on Medicare for 13
years I felt it was time for me to go
back and look and see what's going on so
I made some charts okay okay spear
second Rec pus m i no I will be glad to
give anybody a
copy yes yes I would be glad to email my
charts cool okay one of the things that
did not come out in this uh in in the in
the meeting is that there are no more
Medicare standard plans that cover Plan
B uh plan Part B
deductibles it used to be a plan F that
was discontinued yeah f it used to be a
plan C but that became Medicare
Advantage yes right now according to
CMS there are no plans to cover the
deductibles there are a couple of plans
K and L that cover plan a deductibles
but at the rate of 50% or 75 5% with
out-of pocket maximums of 7,200 or 3600
depending on what you have there is one
advantage that I can see a Medicare
standard that Medicare Advantage doesn't
have and that is Medicare standard
covers the entire United States there's
only one network Medicare Advantage is
Network area specific manage and not not
manage care that everything it has nwor
it can be P or it can be uh po which is
not you don't need a referral or it can
be HMO which means you do need a
referral and you can specify the size of
your network to include down into
Massachusetts or you can me actually
specify it to be your local area your
town you know nashille right the depth
can also be specified how many doctors
in that area and the percentages for the
doctors are can run 30 % for a local
area low depth or a broad depth area of
you know that includes
Massachusetts uh at 70% of the doctors
in that area so you can select plans all
across that but the advantage that
Medicare Advantage has that Medicare
regular doesn't have is whatever these
supplemental plans are in Medicare
Advantage there's no supplementals per
se you you are free to switch from any
version of the plan you want every
single year and your uh your
pre-existing conditions are
covered according to uh Kaiser Family
Foundation only 2% of people switch
between plans most people are satisfied
they switch back and
forth they say to use Medicare now the
only recommendation I see for Medicare
standard is if you are uh living in two
states you know for instance let's say
you go to Florida for 6 months a year
and then New York for 6 months a year
you might want to go with standard
Medicare because you're covered in both
carriers whereas if you live in one
place
essentially then you would get Medicare
Advantage 95% according to kff 95% of
Medicare Advantage uh clients are very
satisfied with their coverage they're
finding no problem you can start out at
65 and thinking that you're healthy and
believing you're not going to get into
an accident and go with a very minimal
plan that cost L anything or you can
have a pre develop a pre a condition
where you need to have some real careful
care and then you're going to have to
pay more money for the plan and get it
get a broader deeper plan and you get to
have to pick your insurance company
whichever one you feel good about and
there's a whole pot load of those and
you get to so you have a lot of choice
and maybe the best thing somebody has to
do is to consult somebody who
understands all these things and I will
be glad to email out my little charts
and you
can pick your own insurance
so my recommendation is we should just
kind of stop the bill
because it doesn't do what people think
it's going to do you can't switch back
to Medicare and think you're going to
get deductibles played they don't play
them
anymore
so so representative spe second by
representative pusc moves inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 185 is there any
discussion on the
motion seeing none all those in favor
please raise your hand one
two oh okay just here one two 3 four uh
so silly oh what was the right what was
okay spe
say I I think I feel almost almost
241 fine next
up uh Al spill 241 relative treatment of
alternatives to
opioids um so you well I sent out an
amendment and ran up the flag uh but the
um sponsor is begging us to retain this
Bill yes have we seen your
Amendment
uh I don't know did
uh uh that is true you might not have
gotten it um it was I mailed I yeah I
mailed it out um you me he was drawn up
by Alex at the department and so the all
the carriers got it and then and he got
it and he yeah I guess you I guess you
didn't get it so but I was waiting for
his
okay you know so and it was it was
basically the I would say the the rub
right now in terms of the way you know
the issue is is how do we and make sure
patients are well informed in terms of
making the choices about what they do
and the problem is is so my the way we
wrote the amendment was well that means
we're going to have the insurance
companies you know send out a letter to
to the patients and say you know uh what
what are all the different Alternatives
that are available to them that um it it
sort of reachs that we're practicing
medicine so that that creates a problem
and we don't want to we don't want to
get into that that situation yeah I just
wanted to say for the record that um we
don't have we don't have information
about the efficacy of some of these
treatments you know and you know I was
re I mean apparently massage works for
some things and not for others etc etc
so I'm not comfortable giving a blanket
um well it was narrowed we definitely
narrowed it down to the ones that were
already were already you know like I
mean the big one is chiropractic is
already satory you know but in the
Statue but I think that um I think
what's really
important that we most need and I'm not
saying this for the camera that is for
people you know is the um the nature of
healthc care has had in my all my years
have been doing this job is that um that
manage care was always about how you
know what we do to get you
healthy and mental health really kind of
brought out that well that's a problem
because that um some people are never
you know with mental health issues
you're you're you're that you have that
for the rest of your life and so now we
get into
maintenance and well Managed Care is not
that's not one of its favorite things to
be doing is maintenance you know is that
there it's more built around let's you
know how do we get
you cured and um I think that this bill
brings out the the same issues we have
with mental health which is and then and
I and I was this was acutely Weare of
this back as I was in the room when uh
we took up um Chiropractic and the way
the Chiropractic tattoo you know
originally was that you know insurance
companies were were treating it mostly I
I would say like mental health you know
the utilization review that they you
know how many times they'll give you x
amount of visits but then after that
they were cutting you off and the cutter
packed and that back then there was two
kinds of chiropractor lobbyists there
was uh one who was the streets the other
was the mix and I won't tell you who the
names of the people but but but it was a
very interesting because there was two
different you know coming in and the
issue was um how how to make sure that
CH you know that people wanted
chiropratic forever they they want to
get the get the twist forever and so the
the end end result was um is that uh we
did pass the bill that says if the
insurance company covers chiropractor
that yes you can get 12 visit it's a
year and with deductibles and you know
you know copays and whatever and that's
been on the Statue feels like 20 years
it feels how long it's been out there um
so that is already on the books it's out
there um and so it really is sort of a
baseline but um sure enough um siga and
I can use that name because they don't
they're not in the small group Market
anyways but they actually uh it was
called Health Health Source I I forget
what was the name Health Health Source
at the time and they they actually
dropped Chiropractic when we passed that
that mandate and but eventually um they
they did eventually turn around and
cover it but um but that just goes to
show that when we do a mandate there is
a implication to you know to the
companies who whether they want to abide
by it or not so Mr chair could you
define twists the twists
yes well that's what I call it and I
would say um years ago I haven't been to
a chiropractor in a very long time but
when I yeah a really long time and I and
and I do remember when I was picking up
my father-in-law and you picked him up
and and but when I go I I would go to
the cack and they do that where they lay
over and do that that twist and and and
I would say over my life at that back
then you know three three times and
every time they just one twist was all I
needed and I was good to go um and they
would always say don't you want to come
back again and I go I'll let you know
whether I need it or not and they never
did so
okay so um I'll make the motion to
pusc okay any discussion on the motion
to
retain see none all those in favor raise
all right
next house 648 relative to insurance
coverage for glucose
one we've gone over a lot of the um
reasons why we should be doing this and
I feel very strongly
that this kind of monitoring is very
important and it's going to stop
problems in the future the problem I
have and it's a something I've balanced
everything with is it going to risk
taking people off the off off the
insurance roles and it turns out I I did
an analysis and at least as long as I've
been here which isn't all that long the
bills that we have mandated without
funding have amounted to about at most
$2 a
year this one based on analysis provided
by Jason uh
AES uh is going to amount to $22 a year
and that's $22 a year per family member
and that is
risky my recommendation is we retain the
bill see if we can narrow it down a
little bit and get the cost down a
little more right and so my
recommendation is to REM is to retain
it yeah I in terms of negotiating this
bill and finding and trying to get an
understanding of what is going on now
with the insurance companies who were
who in the state and um it really gets
down to the question of how often you
test yourself on a daily
basis that if you are just sticking your
your a andc is not high enough you're
just sticking yourself once a day you
know to see how you're doing um that
that
obviously does not necessarily mean that
you're really really need it whereas
this machine is clearly necessary if
someone's A1C is is bouncing around and
and on a daily basis then yes the the
protocol is that you should absolutely
have one of these monitors and far as
we're understanding is that all the
insurance companies in the state will
cover you if you have multiple you know
you know you need to test yourself
multiple times a day so that's right I'm
I'm I'm s I'm just right so that's the
reason why we're retaining that so we're
going to find out whether that's really
true or not and really get into the
groundwork and finding out what what the
situation is
so um yeah good good idea but just me
you're not testifying you're just
sharing
okay chatting just chatting as rep hope
Damon uh retired diabetes educator and
dietitian um so in response to your
remarks Cher
hun I don't have the same understanding
on a couple points so
one
um not all insurance companies will pay
for continuous glucose
monitoring for patients whose diabetes
is not treated with insulin and we now
have in the landscape of Diabetes
Care a considerable number of noninsulin
pharmaceutical options for type 2
diabetes and it is wonderful that we
have those options in part because while
insulin will effectively control blood
sugar you know folks need to learn how
to use it and how to dose and so forth
it will work to lower blood sugar for
sure however it is also associated with
weight gain and weight gain is a primary
variable in increasing risk of
complications of diabetes such as heart
disease the newer non-insulin
medications are generally not associated
with weight gain
so they're desirable for a number of
reasons excuse me but I'd highlight that
one in
particular that we are decreasing
healthare cost when people with type 2
diabetes use medications like one
category is SG
lpt2 um alphabet
soup when we decrease the risk of
complications we not only help that
person have good control of diabetes and
go on about their productive life we
help them not have the complications
that cause so much money
so that variable of insurance companies
covering
CGM for noninsulin treated patients I
think is a very important
consideration the other piece I'd note
in response to your good introductory
remarks is yes CGM is more important for
people who already were finger stick
testing multiple times a day whether to
determine the dose of their insulin or
to better understand their diabetes or
because they um have a great deal of
fluctuation in their blood sugars and so
they're trying to stay safe like being
safe to drive you should not be driving
when your blood sugar is
plummeting
um however many people don't test
anywhere near as frequently as would be
desirable to do for a whole host of
reasons um one could simply be that you
know it's not particularly comfortable
to stick your finger it's not horrible
you get used to it to a degree but it's
not pleasant there are people who have
needle phobia who just cannot muster the
ability to do that frequently they're
they're just in a very very distressed
State over the procedure of doing that
there are people who have Parkinson's
disease or other causes of Tremors and
they literally physically can't really
do it effectively so they need somebody
to help them or people who are in their
workplace setting they don't have a
situation where they can just run off
and check their blood sugar and they
can't do it at their workstation where
they're working if you have a CGM all
you have to do is grab your phone and
just read it or it alerts on your phone
automatically depending on the device
so I I guess I'd like to ask if it's
okay for me to ask the committee are
there folks here who who are not yet
convinced of the need for
CGM in any person with diabetes who is
willing to use it to treat their
diabetes Well you just threw a curveball
I did yes because you were talking about
insulin okay so no nobody in this room
is going to argue that someone who has
to take insulin on a daily
basis that there needs to be proper
monitoring of taking that insulin what
you've just said is oh no forget about
those people now let talk about the
people who are taking a medication for
their a
andc and um and have not not don't need
insulin that brings first of all forget
about the people with insulin I would
never in a million years say that but
that isn't an issue in this bill because
as you noted
correctly the people who take insulin
already have access to CGM whether
they're type one or type 2 I do not
believe that that is a problem but only
30% of people 30 35 Le um of people with
type two diabetes are treated with
insulin some of those people are not
treated with insulin because they won't
do an injectable medication similar
reasons to the issues with finger sticks
many of them are not treated with
insulin because we have better ways to
treat it the meds that I referred to
some of which are oral and some of which
are injectable so that's I'm sorry that
sounded like a curveball cuz I thought
we had talked about you're testing
yourself multiple times a day even even
if you're on a pill did you only a pill
that take you only take that pill once a
day you so that depends on the
individual patient and it depends on
where their diabetes management is at
and it's not a static resp response even
for the individual patient so for
example we might say to a patient newly
on a non-insulin
medication we might recommend that they
check their blood sugar several times a
day for the first two weeks to see how
are they responding to that how's it
working do we need to make adjustments
do they need to time their eating
differently or their
exercise what all the variables are
right and then if if
their uh results are good and
consistent they might not need to test
as frequently and that person might be
well informed by a CGM but I don't know
that I'd say it was necessary that I
want you to understand that's exactly
why we're retaining this bill we're
trying to figure out that threshold
we're trying we have we're we are
obligated obviously in terms of figuring
out what we're going to mandate to the
insurance companies and what they have
to do is that we have to said draw this
line where is the
appropriate
level and you know obviously you you
know we might not agree on this issue
okay but and as I can't you know you
know refer representative spe says these
machines are not cheap okay and you know
the and you you're going to get a new
new one or whatever yeah represent
Spirit you want follow up I wanted to
make a comment on that none of us are
doctors none of us can say what the real
scope of how diabetes should be managed
right and I've looked at it every way I
can with with Hope's help every way I
can and on the surface not being a
doctor I think we got to do something
but one thing I do know is
numbers and $22 a year per family member
is going to knock people off the
insurance roles and that I do understand
and can talk
to and so while I can't talk to the
medical part of it I can talk to that
part of it right can can I ask I
somebody from either the the insurance
department do you agree with that
assessment that it would be $22 a person
per year so the before he speaks the $22
was based on the unamended bill when it
included the exemption from deductible
and
copay
so with the
amendment with the devices
being um subject to
deductible the $22 is no long why we
have to retain it because we don't have
those numbers we would we would we need
to have that study done
yeah yeah do you want to hear from the
insurance I wasn't prepared to talk on
this Jason AES director health E omics
from the insurance department we did
write a fiscal note on this bill I just
want to point out two two key things
that the technique that we use is we try
to identify the marginal cost of this
mandate if it were enacted so how much
does each unit cost with all of the
other things note noteworthy are um the
clinical requirements that are also
associated with which are 18 months I
would suggest those or are organized in
the plan year not 18 months just for con
in cost reporting but the um then we
multiply that times the new eligible
population that's the spous part because
the technique we use is how many people
become eligible that weren't previously
eligible if this bill were to become law
and I just wanted to point out that
insulin therapy status is the current
eligibility criteria not frequency of
blood um is correct right so so we look
at What proportion of the population who
have diabetes have type 2 diabetes and
of them What proportion as
representative Damon stated um are
currently on any type of insulin therapy
and it's it's approximately 30 to
32% um as a as a side note it is
noteworthy that Medicare has reduced the
criteria for that eligibility basis
based on three multiple daily injections
down to two as of April 2024 so you do
see this indeed this migration away from
the intensity of insulin therapy as a
criteria
taken together that value I think that
representative spear is talking about is
the upper limit of the um absolute cost
if taken all things together if this
bill were
enacted knowing that it'll never be 100%
of the new eligible population that
would take this up but some unforeseen
proportion of that which is that why we
put indeterminable because we don't know
that it's it's it's having one one for
years is it's quite invasive and it's
actually it adds to the work burden of
managing the chronic disease of diabetes
so we know that it's not going to be
100% so it's hard to predict what will
be the absolute fiscal impact if this
bill would become LW but I have a couple
of suggestions I think that we could
make this bill more narrow if we better
Define the eligible population I heard
represent that's what that's exactly
what we're saying we're talking about
this so bifurcating the different types
of diabetes Therapies in the type two
population those who take medication
those who don't and maybe what types of
medication right and that and that's the
we hope okay so just everybody
understand what retaining means means we
will re come back to this in
September and and work on it in
September and we will have to vote on it
has to come out of committee uh by the
end of October and it'll be on the house
floor in January but if you want to work
on it over the summer and we can get
nailed down an amendment really good
in the usual way that I have I'd be glad
to help work with that happy to help I
work at the behest of commissioner bet
cour so his directive we're happy to
help elucidate and he seems to listen to
us so we will make sure that thank you
so much so I just I just want to ask
representative spere where where did you
uh how did you get the $22 a person that
was in the fiscal note okay well no not
exactly if you remember at the end of
list here uh Dr AIS gave us a report
okay that's right that's right and I
used that report as the
basis and then calculated the numbers
and sent it back to him and he said it
okay see are you a lawyer too then not
just a
doctor okay so uh you I see you had your
hand up I think she did the hand for us
okay represent thank you Mr chairman um
just a comment that I think retaining
the bill is the best idea specifically
in light of the uh page two uh lines 1
through six where it discusses not
needing a prescription for this medical
device um so I think that's something
that certainly needs to be taken up in
it
okay yes um I think because of two
reasons this bill should be considered
one is that I don't agree uh the
insurance company's definition of
medical necessity which is in the bill
is already somebody taking insulin and
in that part but the issue is that when
you go to the doctor for diabetic
related diabetes or diab problems the
doctor doesn't see that the doctor
basically prescribes that based on the
status of your how how far along you are
in diabetes in a reading etc etc right
the insulin therapy is not the threshold
that they prescribe this machine they
prescribe it before that also so there
is a big difference between the medical
necessity definition from the insurance
department and the medical practice
Department that is something needs to be
looked at and right now the insurance
company keeps following the standard
that they have put in place for medical
necessity so that needs to be Revisited
with the definition of what the medical
community or medical
providers they look at it as necessary
to have this that is one thing second
thing is that this device I mean right
now what we are always struggling is
that we try to prescri we we try to
cover this by insurance only when the
diabetes goes to the final level when
you get into insulin therapy which is
the last stage of diabetes basically if
if you if you allow people to have this
device as is what medical community or
medical doctors they recommend to use
before this might not you might not go
to that level of diabetes where you need
a insulin therapy I mean diabetes not
diabetes is not measured just because
somebody is taking insulin there are 70%
people who are in diabetic in grave
danger diabetes and they their A1C is
pretty shot up but they don't take
insulin therapy why do you want to wait
uh for people to go to that level when
basically you have nothing you can't do
anything except taking therapy so I feel
that uh and like this bill was saying
that if the medical community of if the
medical doctor who is treating you feels
NE feels necessity of having this device
then that device should be covered by
insurance that would be my argument
towards it to keep this bill okay thank
you okay so yeah I'm not sure if we
covered this in my notes um again this
is a very small small population right
we're talking of the market that will be
required to cover this so we're really
talking about a very small bring up the
fact that it's the problem with that
even we mandate this that small large
employers unfortunately it will just
help a very small population but um the
question that I have is is this covered
under Medicare or Medicaid I was just
looking for a guidance on so what what
what is it you said it was it it still
Med you have to be on insulin so that
was the thing I see that's where that's
why I said you threw a curve
because everything I heard so far when
in terms of my research on this was that
it was insulin driven and now you're
saying oh wait there's some people who
take medications and don't have you know
like I assume like like my met Foreman
that I'm taking because I I reached my
6.4 and another doctor says to me boy
they're they're getting radical starting
because usually it's you see all the
commercials it's you know we'll get you
under seven right you get you you know
seven so so six like Po why am I taking
the Met for well I'm taking it because
you know I'm trying to be proactive
about it okay and and and met foran is
cheapap you
know insurance company doesn't mind
covering it so I I figured that was a
good thing to do but no I I stopped
taking my blood sugar to you know I I
when my first when I first diagnosed I
was taking my blood sugar you know
several times a day just seeing what's
going on and then now I I I have do it
rarely so that that that was really the
the issue with the threshold issue um is
you know and and that's I'm
saying we're not saying we don't want to
pass this bill okay we are we are
absolutely motivated to to pass
something okay and um representative
Street said we absolutely believe that
that that determination is is your
doctor makes that
diagnosis okay the the problem is is
that that you know is the diagnosis you
know is based upon you know the because
that's obviously a doctor patient
relationship okay but that yes the um in
the the relationship in terms of of what
is being prescribed to that physician
you know what he's prescribing and I I
don't know anything about these
non-insulin things I mean I guess it is
so Med foran is considered a non-insulin
bill you're talking about so you're
saying that I should be eligible because
I take metformin that I should be able
to get one of these
would but they wouldn't need a
prescription under this
bill but under this bill they wouldn't
need a do that would that would be
deleted that that would be gone no it
would have to to be a physician you know
at the end of the day yeah the physician
has to describe it you have to you know
so but anyways I just we just want to
know what exactly are the thresholds I
mean what is the the medical necessity
when when does that physician make that
decision and so you know from what I was
what I was reading you know was uh was
that if someone who's being tested
multiple times a day needed be testing
mulle say because their their blood
C critical very appropriate appropriate
let's say
appropriate but I would offer that that
is not the only circumstance and that's
and that's what we want to learn about
and to make sure that we articulate and
legislation we don't we testified
already so this is not a testimony this
is what we're trying to do is work on
the language so you'll help us help us
when we work on this language that
you'll help us
sorry
oh believe it or not it is bring
hospital has BR hospital my appointment
bring this hospital for for something
else for something else can I just have
a quick followup yes please thank you so
then also in the bill is um um in to
qualify for the coverage the uh
recipient must participate in follow-up
care so I just wanted to make sure that
that additional follow-up care at least
uh once every six months during the
first 18 months access to uh teleah
Health Etc I want to make sure that
that's all covered in the cost and how
how that would work which when you do
the when they do a cost analysis that
yes it me your multiple visits correct
and not sure what the coverage would be
currently but this would also need to be
um taken into account so it's on I
believe even based on when we looked at
it that most of the non CGM related
stuff was covered I mean got multiple
visits and all that sort of thing for
anybody with a with a uh an insulin uh
not an insulin a glucose problem does
get monitored yeah right I I think the
monitoring is absolutely necessary but
that needs to be if it's additional
visits how is all that going to be
calculated in the overall right well I I
can just say myself personally that you
know that um I I I do get my blood fed
drawn the fasting blood drawn twice a
year so that insurance you know that so
I've never had any push back from that
and that but that's the requirement
because they we were steadily watching
my blood sugar you know get up and up
and then they move the goal poost back
from 130 to 100
and that's not
it's not fair so anyway yes no that is
absolutely when we do our
fun insurance no right now I'm in so
anyway but I was in the small group so I
was acutely aware of the small group
problem yes represent so I would suggest
that you know rather than uh
debating that what requirements should
be there to allow this as covered or not
covered is and like you know two times
like I said or three times taking test
and the the readings are shooting up and
down who is going to benefit Etc I would
say that let's leave it to
the uh medical doctor U assessment of
whether the person needs or not if the
medical doctor who is seeing the
diabetic patient correct feels the need
of need to prescribe it right it will be
prescribed and then if it's prescribed
the insurance compan instead of keeping
its own threshold I mean own criteria of
covering or not covering which is
currently insulin therapy should just
listen to the medical doctor who is
prescribing it and uh cover it based on
the med the medical necessity as
determined by the medical doctor not
like uh you know like like you said we
we had couple of different criteria I
can assure you whatever we come up with
absolutely that key component yeah is
that the physician is make making that
recommendation so that one one line
language itself will eliminate uh
various uh uh different criteria should
be covered or not covered just that one
line will dictate whether I I wish
sometimes legislation could be just that
simple
that prescription is not required we
probably need to make that language more
clear what the statement the full
statement is anology referral of
prescription shall not be required
because Primary Care Providers can very
effectively
address folks
tyit from CGM don't
necessarily I agree I agree just as long
as the prescription is in place okay
right EXA I agree again that's the devil
in the details that we need to work on
okay so is everybody comfortable with
retaining okay well those in favor say
six okay so that um that was moved by me
and
seconded by yeah is is is he are he is
he on
health cuz
sorry yes okay so are you okay with
retaining this build and for and the
motion is to retain so we're going to
keep working on it okay so the vote is
zip
okay
so
um3 okay so let's I'm going to wait on 7
because representative Cole is not
here he's on housing this morning with
representative Gibbs
and so so let's let's just do 297 and
then I'll clear out the
297 so uh like I said that's
representative Cole and so he's he's in
the other committee
um okay so this I just want yeah we're g
we're going to do 297 then then get rid
of the room and then and then uh lighten
the load here and then and then I'll
call them
um
uh okay we got uh
Arrow
we we're doing
297 what's
that
can replace this replaces 176 H
yes okay no it does not replace 176 was
176 H would be section one of the bill
this one okay now okay that replaces
that amendment
number so just so everyone know so the
way that this is written we got um we
still have the underlying bill
and which is uh is section one of the
bill so section
into a
story if I may Mr chairman yes DJ Betton
cord commissioner of the New Hampshire
insurance department let me speak to the
length of the proposal at this point so
as I mentioned at the outset this is a
program that I very very deeply believe
in I deeply believe in it because I
think
for a small amount of money you can make
a big impact for a lot of consumers when
it comes to the affordability of their
homeowners
insurance and also and really this if it
is not being considered as part of the
larger conversation it really should be
you know I know there's been a lot of
discussion lately about what the state
can do to encourage more housing and to
be able to retain and attract a younger
generation of
Workforce and I know that that was a
huge priority for governor senu it's now
an even bigger priority for governor aot
and all of you in the legislature I know
have worked hard on it and put resarch
ources towards it as well but the piece
of this not to be forgotten as I think
the vast majority of people in this room
know is you cannot get a mortgage from a
bank unless you have homeowners
insurance coverage and if you are a
younger person uh that is not a small
bite when you're at the beginning part
of your career you're not at your Peak
earning potential yet uh and you're
really budgeting tightly and I think
that this is something that can be a
useful tool is part of that overall
effort that the state is currently
engaged
in so because of my belief in the
program because I think it is a useful
contribution to a larger policy issue
you're trying to take on I have engaged
with a number of different legislators
in a number of different capacities to
try to make sure that I'm approaching
this and that we are approaching this in
a way that works for all of you and so
as I mentioned I think the public
hearing when we first brought this
proposal forward I went and met with the
legislative leadership and said how
would you like me to do this would you
like the bill to be more Broad and then
we'll address some of the details in the
rulemaking process or do you want more
detail in the statute and what they told
me was they wanted as much detail in the
statute as possible so he said okay
we'll do that and then they said we
wanted to go through house Commerce
first so that's why the bill is at this
point as large as it is that is why you
all are dealing with it at the time they
had said they wanted this to come
through this committee the filing period
for legislation had closed thus the non
gerain Amendment route that we
ultimately took and Mr chairman I
appreciate your Indulgence in helping us
make this process work what I'm here to
speak to directly this
morning is an alternative manner in
which the program would be funded and I
noted that when we were at the public
hearing the vast majority of questions
that the committee had asked about were
related to the
finances and having sat in your chairs
not all that long ago I appreciate the
fact that you all right now from a
budgetary perspective are having to
weigh some difficult choices and some
options and I appreciated the fact that
the million dooll ask that would come
from the IP that would ordinarily go
into the general fund but would instead
go to this program was going to be an
ask and I understood
that
so I brought it Forward th that was
where your focus was I have tried to
structure this program as cheaply and
efficiently as possible as you know no
additional staff will be needed for this
we're really trying to run it very lean
and very efficiently so two Fridays ago
the department had its presentation
before house finance division
1 and at the end of that presentation I
gave them a heads up that this proposal
was currently being worked on by this
committee and that if it came forward my
assumption would be that it would be
referred to finance so I just wanted
them to be aware and it opened up a
larger conversation in which it became
very clear to me that
the million dollars was just not going
to be available for the program so I
said I I understand you know when I said
that there are seven to nine states who
have already implemented this
program had I known then what I know now
in terms of the the detail of this and
the challenge of this I would have said
but none of those seven to nine states
have New Hampshire's unique tax
structure which I think is a very good
one forces us to spend wisely and and be
Innovative which is what we've tried to
do here so in any event a conversation
had broken out amongst the members of
finance division one in terms of the
funding piece and out of that discussion
came the concept that you have
here so what we are proposing to do is
to instead of having an allocation
million dollar allocation from again the
IP that would ordinarily go into the
general fund
we have said that as you all know our
department is funded via an assessment
on insurance carriers it goes through a
formula of the per capita written
premium of that company it gets a little
complicated fortunately we've got a lot
of really smart people in the department
who understand how that all
works so the idea would be we always
assess what the maximum amount the
department is authorized to spend via
the line items in the budget that you
all eventually
pass in the history of the department
almost never have we spent the full
allocation we budget wisely and there
are always some positions that are not
filled either throughout the course of
that fiscal year or good parts of that
fiscal year so there's always some money
that's underexpanded and so when that
happens my belief is
um we've budgeted wisely we've assessed
the companies for this you you give it
back as a credit against the their next
year's
assessment so the idea that came forward
from house finance
was use what you don't spend as part of
the assessment up to a million dollars
transfer that money into this grant fund
and then credit back the rest
to the carriers for their next year's
assessment that was the
concept again as part of the discussion
we then included a provision in there
that said that if for whatever reason
the department did spent um such that
there was not a million dollars left
over at the end of the fiscal year that
we would assess the Delta between
whatever was being put into the fund and
whatever was needed to be put into the
fund for the balance to be a million
dollar so for example if the department
really went Gang Busters and had a
phenomenal year recruiting and filling
positions and we spent a lot of money
and we only had say 500,000 that we had
not expended that fiscal year the
500,000 would go into the fund and then
we would assess a 500,000 to make up the
million I appreciated that that
emergency provision would be
controversial again it was feedback we
had taken in from house finance division
one we want the program to go
forward seemingly that would be a
concept that would work for them but if
you're afraid of having us do an
additional assessment again I think we
can live without it number one because
um we've never spent to the degree that
we would need to do
it uh but number two is I would be
perfect L fine to say if we only had a
half million dollar to put into the fund
for a particular fiscal year the
announcement would go out and say we're
now accepting applications for the
granted State home risk and resiliency
program we have up to 500,000 in Grants
to give out this year first come first
curve serve let's go doesn't have to be
a million so if you want to take out
that particular provision again so we
could call it a pilot
program you could call it whatever you'd
like if you as long as it goes forward
Mr chairman um so Mr chairman as you
know we were hammering out the final
details of this amendment as of the late
uh morning hours yesterday and so we got
it to representative hunt as soon as we
were comfortable with it as we always do
we then sent a copy of it to Industry I
have not gotten any feedback Beyond a
very brief conversation with one
industry representative as I was coming
in this morning my understanding is that
they're
concerned so and and it seems that it's
less concern they're equally concerned I
guess about both both aspects of what we
propose I'll be candid with you I was a
little bit surprised that they objected
to the first part of it I thought there
would be some push back on the provision
that allowed for an emergency assessment
which again was not something that I
felt was absolutely necessary for this
to work I don't know the full details of
those
concerns what I can say is that we did a
very rough calculation of what the what
a million dollars would mean on average
to a company in terms of the credit
towards their assessment and the very
rough math figures came out to
approximately again because it's prad
it's going to be different for different
companies anywhere in the neighborhood
between $40 to
$80,000 per
company and by the way my understanding
is that industry treats their assessment
as a sunk cost because there's no
guarantee what they're going to get back
at the end of every fiscal year it
depends on how we
budget so from my view this may very
well be a case where we're going to
agree to disagree with industry we work
hard to try to find consensus we always
work collaboratively and I appreciate
the fact that it came together late so
that we didn't get the ability to get
full feedback from industry but there's
obviously a ways to go in this process
there'll be an opportunity for that but
if they
fundamentally disagree with the idea
that we would be able to retain some
portion of what we did not spend in our
budget for this program again that's
just going to be an instance where we
have a difference of opinion and that's
okay so that is what you have here I'm
happy to get into details I can do the
musical chairs so it's a very big chair
with members of my team if you want to
get if you want to just pull up a seat
over here and I'm sure George will love
George um so
yeah want yeah this is a subcommittee
this is not you know
informal right remember the old days
where I used to just we would all sit at
the far in one end the committee room
and okay so just have a take yes
representative spear has a question when
we when last we spoke about this bill uh
the funding mechanism
was the the taxes that are paid on the
licenses is my understanding I could be
totally wrong the taxes that were paid
on the licenses would fund this this
program and now you're talking about an
assessment can you explain what the
difference is sure
so
again as we thought about this program
we discussed a couple of different ways
to approach the funding of it initially
my preferred funding source was what the
state of Oklahoma does so the state of
Oklahoma takes all of the licensing fees
registration fees that they collect for
Surplus lines companies and they put it
into the fund that's become their direct
Revenue source for their program and I
said that sounds pretty good to me until
I found out that in New Hampshire we
only generate about $38,000 worth of
registrations for Surplus lines
companies
I'm not going to get very far with this
program with $38,000 so it forced us to
have to consider a different
option and we went through a couple of
different options we appreciated the
fact that some of those options were
going to touch a nerve for industry we
wanted to see if we could thread the
needle to get everybody on board so I
said look we will come out of the gate
to with a proposal that will let us
retain the first million dollars ofe of
insurance premium tax revenue that we
collect and put that into the
fund industry I I don't want to speak
for them they could speak for themselves
my understanding was the industry was
fine with that
approach then as I've said who was not
fine with that approach was house
finance division
one and I understand why I understand
the challenge you guys are going through
so based off of their conversation about
this now has come forward this proposal
so to your I directly to your
question again when we first started it
was million dollar of Ip into the fund
that's
straightforward that wasn't available
you guys need the million dollars for
the things so the assessment piece of it
is again how the department is funded
we're self-funded
agency so we take the total amount of
the Department's budget what we're fully
allowed to to spend for that particular
fiscal year so it's somewhere in the
neighborhood of 15
million this that we're proposing for
the budget that's currently under
consideration um so that's what's going
to go out it'll go through that formula
per capita written premium for that
company the check comes in there it is
and so what we're saying is if we don't
spend a 15 million the full amount that
we've been authorized to spend we can
retain up to a million dollar of
that and fund the program that way which
is a stable funding mechanism going
forward yes the amount might change I
don't really think we'd ever get below a
million but I'm not going to be
commissioner
forever um but the other benefit is it
does not have to go through the budget
process every other year and have to be
weighed against all of the other
priorities that you have to consider but
what is the term assessment mean in this
context the word assessment what you
assess it we're assessing the insurance
companies who do business in the okay
yeah uh I've done a Lely job of
explaining this now two weeks in a row
she's a little new no no no fine he all
this is what this is your second term
yeah I don't what the word assessment
exactly go for
it so so anyways um Vermont
uh they pay for the insurance department
out of the general
funds okay the all expenses to pay for
all employees pay for everything okay uh
and and they do that for insurance and
banking too okay we we don't do it that
way here in New Hampshire and here in
New Hampshire um we uh expect the users
of a department like the insurance
companies like the insurance companies
or like the banks with the bank the bank
the users to pay for the Departments I
see and so the assessment system is
created uh and it when he was talking
about how have rocket Sciences figure
this out like you okay because there's
lots of little formulas it's like the
Dow Jones you know when you come in and
it's a different number you know and
it's it complicated because it's based
upon a the type of Industry okay and and
you know whether it's Property and
Casualty versus health insurance that
each one's different okay and that we
have an assessment system that we make
anybody who is a domestic insurance
company um pay the Lion Share we
definitely try to get all the other
property and casual companies that
participate in our state and we're very
have a very Lively property and casually
don't have mandatory Auto okay so we we
have a good Market a lot of companies
that come in and do business um uh they
pay you know they pay they get their
assess everybody gets assessed to help
Finance the department so that's what
he's talking about but that that is we
have to be proactive we have to assess
them first based upon our budget but
then when all said and done after the
year is over there could be employees we
didn't field jobs didn't happen
different things that could have
happened in terms of that year and
that's why there's often a surplus and
that's where that's what we're tapping
in is that Surplus um normally would be
just give apply to payments for next
year for those in companies but that
we're saying let's we're going to carve
out a a little bit to help this property
and casually
industry neita thank you I just have a
quick question commissioner can't see
you
um I'm sorry um you me you sighting here
you know sounds like the possibility of
federal grants or money I assume that's
close to nil possibility at this point I
would never dare to predict what's going
to happen in Washington I think we can
right now so that's it's in the bill
simply that if there if there was then
they wouldn't have to come back they
wouldn't have to have to come back and
ask permission take the money there has
been conversation about the federal
government making grants available to
States for either the promotion of these
programs or to uh help supplement the
state funding and I think it would be a
great thing uh if the federal government
were to make those grants available we
would obviously be able to expand the
number of people that we would be able
to help the key question would be Beyond
whether or not it was actually ever made
available the other key question would
be how many strings do they attach to
those dollars and would that work within
the constructs of our program now and if
the strings were common sense but it
still didn't quite fit right I would
come to you and say we need to make a
couple of tweaks here so we can get
these federal dollars in but if it's too
overwhelming we may not be able to make
use of it so when I've talked with our
federal delegation about this I've said
to them I think those grants could be
very helpful to States I absolutely
believe in the benefit that it could
provide to Consumers but please as you
make those grants available do not make
the requirements around them so
prescriptive that they don't fit or
can't work within how each state has
program okay well get to you George I
promise that's all
right represent brail thank you so I
I've been trying to research the direct
the purpose of the program is to lower
Insurance costs for property owners
right property insurance and I've been
trying to resar no it's not it's not
lowering but this is what this is is is
preemptive no I understand that he's
trying to get the rates to come down is
what I've been hearing yes yes if I if I
might so not seeing the connection
between cutting my trees down and right
I might not have a claim for that and
having insurance rates maybe be a little
bit more competitive sure so let me
explain how this would work because
representative Hunt's right this is a
prospective looking program not anything
that would be later or post event those
would be things that FEMA would get
involved with the way this program is
structured is when you are getting a
quote for a homeowner insurance policy
or when you've come up for renewal for
your current homeowners insurance policy
they're going to put you through an
underwriting process each company has
their own underwriting factors those get
looked at by the department to make sure
they're not discriminatory or anything
of that nature and
so they'll look at your property or
they'll take an aial photo of your
property and they'll plug what they
see into their underwriting formula and
then it will spit out what your premium
should be and there are things like
value of the home there's a number of
different components but some of the
components that we've heard as of late
that have driven a lot of premiums
upward are things related to the
property or the external part of the
house roofs those trees I was speaking
of being able to shore up the foundation
to guard against flood and so what the
program is designed to do is to speak to
those underwriting guidelines so the
eligibility of what you can use your
funds for is directly tied to an
underwriting factor and so when you come
up for
Renewal you're going to be in a better
position if you've fixed the roof if
you've done whatever needs to be done
because you're going to feare better in
that underwriting process and so your
premium in in um ideally would come
would come down but at worst our hope is
that it will prevent you from not
getting
non-renewed and having to go try to get
coverage through the Surplus lines
Market which is very very
expensive does that hopefully answer
your
question well this I well yeah here's
I'll give a story you you know me I love
stories okay so let's say
um you your uh your company the
insurance company says we would like to
do visit you want to come check it
out and and you're there you you see the
the guy is coming in and and looking at
it over and he's got his clipboard and
he's checking these things up and then
all of a sudden he looks
up and you you have your your children
they're they're on a swing under one of
the limbs of this tree swinging back
back and forth and he looks
up and he says that's a very big
tree and then write something down on
his
board and you your first instinct is he
doesn't like that
tree and that he might when it comes
time to set your
rate
Say it'll be a little higher because
they see a risk there
so what this bill would say
is now now obviously this is not set I
mean there's not I don't think you ever
get a letter that say cut that tree down
or we're not going to you know give you
Jance but but he just you just sense
that you know I I know that tree is a
problem and but I never dealt with the
tree because it's going to cost me 10
grand to take it down because he have to
come over with this big Crane and pull
each limb off
separately and so this is a program in
which the New Hampshire insurance
you all right
so say is every time I get a new
insurance policy and I've had a couple
I've had I had this thing come out and
and and one of them came out and
said you have two dogs I said yeah I got
me this sorry get rid of the dogs yeah
we're not expanding criteria to get rid
of docks
um we gave back $2.6 Million last year
so they'd still be getting back one
under that scenario they'd still get
back
1.6 um and the other thing that to
represent pelli a lot of a lot of times
the reason you don't see somebody in
person coming out is there's been a
greater Reliance on aerial photography
from companies which brings with it
efficiency not having to bother you we
sometimes run into some challenges with
accuracy of the photos we had a a
consumer quite perplexed that they were
non-renewed based on the condition of
their property in the photo they got of
their neighbors
property right so we had to do a little
Outreach to the company to say you got
the wrong house uh but that may be one
of the reasons you don't see that would
not be one of our New Hampshire
domestics right George
possibly okay George tell us what's
wrong what what your issues are and
whether we can fix than I think I know
all all of you because I've I've been
testifying but George Russo is my name
I'm a lawyer in conquered and I
represent different Insurance
associations along with my partner
lindsy NATO who has also testified I
think before you and
so when we first heard about this
initiative from the commissioner several
months ago speak close to the mic I'm
sorry just pull the mic there you
go uh our first concern was uh
funding uh because it seems a natural
thing to say well uh here's the program
and it's going to be funded by let's say
existing premium tax dollars which was
the way this bill was originally
drafted and say well wait a minute why
don't we just raise new money from the
insurance companies instead of having a
million dollars Less in into the general
fund uh and so that risk was Paramount
and we expressed it to the
commissioner um and as the commissioner
mentioned uh we had no objection to the
original a
bill um but again very concerned about
the funding so sure enough what happened
as the commissioner outlined is he went
before finance and they said well this
bill is going to cost the state a
million dollars that it that it
evidently we don't have right so uh so
here we are and I want to thank the
commissioner he's been uh great at uh
working with us communicating with us on
on this uh and other issues as well and
we almost always uh find agreement on
matters of public policy and here the
commissioner let us know about the uh
his his uh hearing meeting with finance
and and and the prospect that they're
looking for funds uh so here we are we
sent it around yesterday afternoon and
we've gotten a lot of feedback between
yesterday afternoon afterno and now from
companies expressing
concerns um I'd like to First mention um
so we're clear about the taxes and fees
that insurance companies pay currently
to the state of New Hampshire there's a
premium tax that varies from 1.25 to 2%
of gross premium that is paid before
that insurance companies pay a bet the
business Enterprise tax
then it they they pay the premium tax
with a credit against the
BET and then a business profits tax to
the extent that the premium tax uh is uh
less than the BPT so they pay the higher
of the business taxes that businesses
pay uh and the insurance premium tax in
addition to that as the commissioner
mentioned uh insurance companies fund by
assessment the budget of the insurance
department um that budget is roughly $10
million uh it it keeps going up but um
around that amount of money um we're one
of only I think about seven
states that fund the department uh by
assessment rather than through general
fund that number may change I haven't
checked in a long time but roughly that
number a minority of states
in
addition uh insurance companies pay fees
uh licensing fees and so forth to the
department that again these are rough
numbers but the last I knew was a couple
$1,000 a year to the department for its
services even though those services are
already paid because the budget's fully
paid for by the
Assessments in addition insurance
companies uh fund the workers comp
division of the Department of Labor
uh and
so uh it is
a highly taxed to begin with compared to
most
corporations
um this bill is a new tax of a million
dollars well that you just killed it
well that's what it
it George and I always thought you were
a nice guy I no I I I I uh we support
this initiative um uh but uh uh it it to
to charge uh premium payers because
that's where money to pay taxes and
everything else comes from uh for a
program that
benefits it doesn't benefit just
insurance companies but it benefits the
general public that's that's really the
reason for it is proove promote home
safety um and by the way the assessments
that would pay for it under this
amendment uh apply to not just property
Casualty Insurance companies but to life
insurance companies and uh and and other
companies uh hmos and so forth that pay
the assessment uh is but isn't the
assessment variable based upon which
industry it is no this the premium tax
is but the the assessment is is you take
as a denominator the the total premium
in New Hampshire and then the numerator
is is the individual companies premium
in New Hampshire oh how much they do B
business ecomic business they do in the
state that's correct that's correct so
uh this struck a sensitive uh uh nerve
with insurance companies uh uh now you
can say this isn't a tax it's it's an
assessment which is a fee uh to pay the
budget of the insurance department but a
fee as you know has to be
constitutionally has to be related to
the cost of the services being provided
and here there's no relationship between
the home resiliency program and and the
fees so it's either an illegal fee or or
a new tax depending upon how you
characterize it so you say it's a
million dollars well uh it's a million
dollars
today that's fine uh
what about other states now the this
these initiatives are coming up in other
states I think the commissioner
mentioned six or seven states that have
a program similar to this one um and uh
States talk to each other and if this is
passed and and there's the word got out
that we did this yeah then other states
are going to be inclined to do the same
thing so that's a concern in addition
this is gets a little complicated the in
the world of
Taxation uh pre reciprocal uh
taxes uh are um yes only exist with
respect to insurance and and the way
that works is the states say if you
charge a fee or a tax to our Indiana or
Illinois company in New Hampshire we're
going to charge that same fee and that
same rate to your New Hampshire
companies doing business in our state so
it's a tit fortat situation and so a lot
of times when these uh uh taxes and fees
are uh implicated it not only costs the
million dollars that we pay to New
Hampshire but every other state has the
ability to retaliate and and to charge
us for the similar program as though
they had a program in their state and so
you multiply the the uh the exposure
that a company has to uh retaliatory
Insurance taxes that's another concern
so yeah obviously you and I have been
around yes this issue right because we
we tried to lower the premium tax yes
and what is our tax rate now it's a
1.25% for property casualty companies
it's 2% I believe for health uh and and
life 2% was still they maintain the 2%
we got the 1.2 so the fact is is that we
could have uh that because of the
reciprocality in terms of what what
happens and that you know us the fact
that we lowered our rate that had the
effect of even for all those other
companies who were doing business here
so it has been a revenue decliner so if
you were not sitting in this room but
sitting over there in in ways and means
you would say why in the hell did they
lower the premium tax sure and look at
the implications so they would probably
wouldn't take this bill lightly given
that we've already taken money out of
their their pocket so to say and you we
do go back this goes back to 2006 and uh
you so it was a hard fun battle it it
was that it was a hard I have a
question to you said that because this
is a fee I have two questions sure you
could ask one yeah based on something
you said yep you said because this is a
fee and it doesn't directly affect the
business because it's homeowners and
whatever and I question that if that
tree falls on the house you have to pay
out sure so this definitely mitigates
future damage that you're going to have
to pay on so the fee is definitely
within scope of your business is my
feeling about that yeah or if it slides
into the ocean that's even
worse the fee we're talking
about uh is supposed to be related to
Insurance regulation not to Insurance uh
payments or premiums but to to the
activities of the insurance department
that's what we pay for because we're
regulated by the department okay then
the second question it's a separate
question that is the fundamental issue
is is that okay we're talking about
that's why I brought in banking to say
is okay this this is not the only
Department we do this with we do this
with banking also that uh we we created
this regulatory Authority for the
purpose of creating licenses and you
know what John Hunt's rule of lure oh
yes I know that so we can take it away
from you but then now we got to pay
those bureaucrats we got to pay those
people we got to pay the department to
do what it does and this is how we made
the decision that we weren't going to
ask the taxpayer to pay for it okay it's
really consumer protection it really you
know consumers you know pay for the h
off but in this case in these two
departments we ask to fund themselves
and I would like uh Mr beton Court to
answer the question about the taxes and
can you verify what he was saying about
taxes so George and I obviously have a
bit of a difference of opinion on
this what I would say though
is the argument that this is somehow a
new
tax I don't think is
accurate
um the assessment is currently in
place that's not
changing you know there were some people
who had said why don't we just have in
the bill that you'll separately assess
the companies for million dollars for
this program just the Property and
Casualty people yes there was that
suggestion and I said I don't like that
idea for some of the reasons that George
talked about because I think at that
point it does start to take on the feel
of an additional tax which I don't
support and secondly I'm always very
wary
anytime somebody comes forward with a
proposal to address their particular
program or issue or challenge via an
assessment a separately made assessment
on the companies to address that problem
because then you've created the
precedent and everybody's going to come
forward and look for their particular
issue to be addressed that way so for
those reasons I said no we're not going
to do a separate assessment what we're
going to do
instead is to retain what we don't spend
up to a million dollars because again
there's no guarantee what the companies
are going to get credited back for at
the end of the fiscal year or what they
were
assessed so original bill was was that
they didn't have any skin in the game
right they really like because because
all because all we were taking the money
from is from a not anything to do with
this assessment but doing with this with
one of the few taxes we actually do have
in the state which was the insurance tax
that's right and that and so and that by
the way still by well I understand that
so basically what you know the companies
are saying well that's very nice of you
guys willing to do this favor to us to
help you know your you know that help
people um premiums um uh but and the
money you're using is out of this this
other tax which they've already done
their best we've already lowered the tax
you know much you know some people might
disagree I think representative alme I
don't think was too happy when we we
propose the the decrease in the tax so
um so I I think I think that you in
hindsight I'd say this this is not the
time for this legislation this is this
is yes it's it's it's it's well-
intended uh the initial cause or I guess
we could say is uh would have been great
Wimer flush but you know when when the
revenues were coming in and they say you
know we could have done this in lie of
cutting the tax back then when we did it
but um at at this point um I think it is
kind of hard pressed to to uh use the
assessment system to fund this this
pilot program so if I if I might Mr
chairman to that point I'll share the
same thing with you that I shared with
house finance if that's the position
that you all want to take then let us
draft up an amendment that would
establish the program would say that the
way it will be funded at present is for
any federal dollars or individual or
contributions of any kind should they be
made available we could just drop those
into the program and be ready to go
rather than having to potentially wait
to come back to you to get the program
established while the federal dollars
are sitting there we can give you an
amendment that basically establishes the
program good Keeps Us open for business
should those funds if there was if if
you could identify the
funds I assume you George are you you're
the lawyer are you okay with that yeah I
I I like the idea I wish that part of
the problem is that this came upon us uh
suddenly we really haven't had time to
fully discuss the issue but I I had been
thinking about that and talked with
Lindsay and some of the companies about
doing exactly what the commissioner is
suggesting right now get the structure
in place you you've heard the merits of
the of the underlying uh uh CA the
program uh and and uh and and and so
that work has been done and and and to
allow grants uh I think that and
commissioner knows better than I do but
I think that there was what happens
nobody knows but that there was some
serious interest or or belief that the
federal government was going to step in
and provide grants to the states in this
area who knows whether that's going to
happen but I say that because the a
number of the states that enacted uh
mitigation programs like this one did do
have a provision in their laws that
calls for accepting uh Federal grant
money and in addition to that uh again I
can't make any promises but I I think
that this would allow the opportunity
for private grants insurance companies
may wish to participate uh in in the
program again I can't I can't speak for
that but uh you know we support the
commissioner's uh initiative and this so
if you did uh as has been suggested get
the structure in place wait for a better
time and and see how that works and in
the meanwhile allow for the possibility
that there'll be other other funding
that that that can start to seed see the
the program to go forward and I had a
private conversation with representative
Wier in which he had said he was very
comfortable with that approach as
commissioner why don't you speak to
Association done your dorge move on I um
this is exactly uh and when you
mentioned it may not be the right year I
was hoping that the commissioner would
offer to let the bill go forward uh
Rhode Island just introduced a bill uh
that doesn't have a funding mechanism uh
just to allow for uh grants I think
there is some thought that Washington is
looking at other ways to better use
federal granting and some of this
prophylactic kind of pre planning is
more aligned and so I I think this
underlying um fortified home program is
is worth passing but with George we
agree on the funding thank you okay so I
have a question so under this
program uh if a person gets the grant to
cut the tree for example like you said
yeah so does he have to pay pay back
that money
no to Grant so the question you might
get it might get a $10.99 right yeah so
so so that that raes a question about
the see I don't I don't have a problem
with the you know objective this program
but the implementation part when you
mentioned that first come first basis
correct so now once once this program is
in place yes and uh and obviously people
who would be knowing about it they are
going to apply and first question would
be that how the insurance department or
whichever Department going to oversee
this how are make criteria to give how
much to give or give or not to give that
detail is actually in but the most
important thing is that once you once
you allow someone to get it yes and now
you say the second person applies for it
and you say the fund has run out I me
that that has happened with every take
the solar exemption you know that you
know the federal government yeah there's
a limit to you you can get it and then
it and and they run out of money and say
no no more this year and wait till next
year so yeah that is that happens I see
that I see that under this program there
could be a lot of uh uh situations of
misuse of this program until it unless
it is administered properly yeah in
general I have reservations I mean for
all due respect to all the government
officials in I do have reservations of
government running businesses where you
provide certain grants unless it is done
appropriately with all the wealth and
vels in place there is a situation where
this program can be misused the good
news is it's only 10 grand so you're
you're not going to have anybody making
running off a lot of money Grand but but
yes I hear you that that you but I I my
take on my take is a lot of people won't
take it won't do it because that they
don't really want to lose that tree they
love that tree the dogs and certainly
won't get rid of their dogs I mean so I
would say this is that is a case where
um it is is trying to be proactive okay
you know you you know put yourself in
the in the department shoes that they
get these calls you know every time
there's a bad weather you know event
they're getting calls where people are
upset that that they're you know they
this um whatever claim what their claims
or whatever happened with the wind and
ice or hail and all the all these you
know wonderful things that can happen
and and I'm sure some of the cases are
they go very you know how far to go well
you know I got that ice you know because
the water I got ice and I broke my back
and you know went medical coverage you
know who knows they how far people will
go you know make these phone calls and
and the Department's just saying is you
know what can you know what can we do to
at least make sure that no underwriter
shows up to your property and and you
know says boy that's a big tree that
that it maybe you know it give people an
opportunity and I know myself my summer
home this is not true my home but my
cber house I had these trees that are
just they're really old trees and
they're all starting to fall down um and
and some of them right are on the power
lines and I can I keep saying you know
that's got to get fixed but every time
I've called the utility they let's wait
till it falls down yeah but but in in
that situation when those trees are
anywhere dangerous to the house you
don't want to postpone cutting those
trees just because insurance is not
covering it or you're not getting you
have to do it anyway because is going to
be be doing it anyway yeah if haard to
your own house your own safety this is
an idea to be a motivator so in that
case I'm I'm going to apply for Grant
and get free money and get that done
which I would have done anyway that's
the thing I'm I'm seeing that ah okay so
you think we shouldn't do this at all I
don't think that there a requirement for
this program there is no requirement for
this program this is this was I mean
maybe we can tell why this maybe I'm not
doing a good job here help me out here I
think um we we're focusing on trees
because they're simple the vast majority
of this program isn't about trees it's
about building and rebuilding your roofs
and your structures to the ibhs standard
that which is a fortified home standard
so much of this grant money will be used
to put better roofs on that withstand
windstorms better and so though I think
you know the commissioner was wise to
allow for a wide range um most of this
money will be used to incentivize
consumers to do the better roof so that
we as a state can look at how how those
roofs fair in the next large store and
so then we'll come back in three years
and say we had a bad Windstorm we had a
micr burst and there were five houses in
that microburst area who had the ibhs
Fortified roof did it do better and you
explain what uh ibhs is in international
home um Builders requirement
Insurance building and home safety which
is a an organization funded by the
insurance industry so that we can do
this this learning um the commissioner
was also very smart in in his bill he
put pretty strict income limits so that
this isn't going to just be a a boon to
rich people who want to fortify their
roofs these limits are such that it will
be helping the lowest income homeowners
in New Hampshire um and I think we have
to give him the opportunity to figure
this program out have a few Grant rounds
go and see how it works and we'll come
back uh the initial results from the
Alabama uh fortified home program have
been phenomenal now we have different C
but they probably had all didn't have
the proper not a not even a question
that uh that their Roof Systems are
different a 10 roofs uh but uh the
industry supports fortified homes and
the the test here thank you and if I may
just add to that the word incentives
been used and surely it may very well
incentivize some people to do those
improvements but I want to make sure
that in the term incentivized is not
lost the fact that some
people would absolutely take the steps
to address the roof or the tree whatever
the issue may be if they had the
financial means to do it I mean I'll
I'll embarrass my parents a little bit
my my parents had a very large tree
beloved but it was
dead that for because of how close it
was to their
home it it was going to end up costing
them about
$5,000 and they're on a fixed income um
their favorite son helped them to be
able to do the work um
no I'm the only
boy the the competition wasn't tough um
but um I helped them with the cost of it
but what it drove home to me is that
there are people who would absolutely
want to do the proactive responsible
thing but simply don't have the budget
to be able to do it and so to the extent
that this program could be leverage to
help them bridge the gap between what
they have to contribute towards that and
what it is going to take to complete
that work then again I think we've
opened up a door of opportunity for
people to not only again I'm an
insurance guy here so I'm looking at it
from that perspective but not to be lost
in this whole conversation is the fact
that the home and the property is going
to be physically
safer so that you're not having people
in danger or or in a or at a greater
risk of danger and so I think all of us
would if resources were no limit do
everything we could to make sure that
our property and our homes were as safe
be okay um so where what's section is
Bill yes so Mr chairman just to help it
is page nine and it is the bolded
material
soal numeral s yes that's right so again
Mr chairman if you were willing to allow
us to move forward with just the
establishment of the program but you
wanted the funding mechanism to be I
think the technical term for it is to
accept donations or funds that's what
they call federal grants are made
available for accounting purposes we
could get you that language by the end
of the day today and you'd have it in
plenty of time for the full executive
session well okay yeah actually at this
point I don't even think that this is an
early Bill anymore because if if you're
getting down to it you you're taking all
the funding out so some of the urgencies
out of there
um no no I wouldn't retain it it's you
know we could we we
um you could take what time you'd like
Mr chairman I'm just telling you I could
get you the amendment you need by the
end of the day and then you can yeah
okay do what you like I mean I how how
do people feel that we would take do yes
represent
oh oh the original underlying bill on my
life and help people that was the first
yeah
yes sorry um so allowing them to have
data I think even maybe I'm being a
little cynical but you know it's not
that hard to drill down to figure out
like if you only have a few employers
employees as a self-funded employer you
kind of already know like who your
people are and if they're sick and who's
probably using the most insurance and
costing you the most money so I feel
like allowing them to have their claims
experience could be ripe for wrongful
termination suits I think I believe in
the statute it says that would be
illegal well of course but that's that's
my concern yeah well that was the reason
part it was I worked over at Bae well
you're the sponsor of this bill so she's
you now I worked over at Bae for many
many
years
and the HR department knows exactly who
goes out on medical and what they're
going out on medical for they don't
really start terminating People based on
the claims data that's just an Actuarial
thing that they use they already know
and as a matter of fact in order for you
to come back to work you have to write a
note and get a a whole doctor's
explanation so and I think that most
employers know what what they're what
their people are doing and why they're
going out I agree so therefore I don't
think they need any more of the people's
personal health information right so
this was a department bill
right so yeah why don't you defend it
don't you know have make her have we're
gonna have Dr AIS come back to deal with
this that's a level of detail that only
the maths the original language this is
Bill right okay in the
first all right the carrier
administrator shall also notify the
employer that if such authorization is
provided the commissioner shall provide
the employer access on an annual basis
to the claims data associated with that
employer sponsored
plan and it says experience and that's
very specific information right I would
agree with Miles because see they might
not terminate based on that reason they
would never say that oh I'm tered
because of your medical history and
claims data but they could use that to
determine some other reason you know
like performance or this or that and
that could be a factor but my question
that more that what is the need for an
employer to even get to know this data
why why employer need to have a claims
data information okay so my
understanding is who who call me on this
bill uh nobody in this room okay yeah I
think it was Henry Vu and it was it was
the issue was if you want to shot if
you're a small you're a this is not a
small you're a large employer you're an
Arisa plan okay and wanted to
shop that you wanted you wanted to have
access to your claims data so you can
use it to shop was that what this was bu
with that with my memory that's what
this bill was about it said you're using
around if the carrier was willing to
if the carrier was willing to share
it well says the carrier or shall so I
have right so if the car doesn't want
want yeah
but the Carri didn't want you to shop
around they could say no no the company
I think we're talking company here and
so I think we have to first establish
nire has the best claims database in the
nation right claims database that helps
us do the analysis that you hear from Dr
aiz that helps helps us educate helps
the commissioner educate consumers about
uh the cost of Medical Treatments and
where they're
delivered the best in the best in the
nation we we we've done one of one of
the holes there and it's a hole that's
growing and and continues to grow is
that self-insured groups do not have to
participate in the claims database and
so this is a carrot and a stick to say
self-insured groups if you'll help us
collect your data if you're willing to
have us do that great right and that's
what we that's what is a state we want
the best claims database in return we'll
give you some data back so that you
understand what your what portion of
your fully insured uh expenses or your
claims data as opposed to administrative
expenses as opposed to other costs and
and I would just add to that cuz I think
what representative miles was concerned
about was is there proprietary in
correct or orable protected informable
information I'll use that broad term
protected information that would be made
available to the
company as part of the carrot stick
approach to get them to voluntarily give
the data to which I would say absolutely
not we have very strict confidentiality
requirements currently in statute what
that would look like is anything that
could be anonymized and aggregated it
would not be
specific to XY orz employee that's
protected that is currently protected we
have a lot of very sensitive protected
proprietary data that we collect as a
department at present but it because
you've got those
confidentiality provisions on the books
it dictates how we're able to share with
the
public the data that we've got
so so are you saying that you are you
saying that the data being provided will
be an aggregate
data and not per part employee or per
person absolutely it's got to be AGG
that's right there'd be all sorts of
violations if you started getting into
any sort of identifiable information or
the conditions of the indivual
identifiable yeah that that's a very
very clear long-established no goes on
would you consider a minimum number of
employees in those self-insured plans I
these are all Rises anyway so they're
they're going to be I mean but if like
they can be they can be 20 employees and
that's not hard to figure out aggregate
data on 15 employees 20 employees it's
not hard for the CEO to figure that out
and to know this person's about to cost
year I in a scenario such as that I mean
I think that risk is present
regardless if you're a company that
small you know and
somebody's become pregnant it's going to
be obvious but fortunately we've got
non-discrimination laws that would
prevent that person from being let go
for that reason of course and let's be
candid if you're a 20 employee 20
employee employer your option is going
to be to go into the small group Market
that's right so if you had that if you
had the shock of a million dollar uh
well employee you're going to you're
going to shift next year to a small
group uh plan um that's a level of risk
you wouldn't want to retain as a
business of that size and and I've
talked about this before not only the
small group markets going to be the more
attractive option we are seeing a pretty
steady migration of those small
employers from small group Market
into a version of the individual Market
called ikra it's an acronym I can never
remember what it's an acronym for where
the employer will give the employee a
set amount of money there are tax
advantages to that money and then that
individual employee goes onto the
individual market and purchases a plan
for themselves that's another huge Trend
we're seeing for businesses of that size
representative miles yeah it makes sense
what the gentleman uh back there said
about they' obviously shift in the
upcoming year not have ongoing
right he's a smart guy I like him
and if we had Paula here we would have
three Commissioners in the room at the
same
time okay you you feel better about it
how do you feel about it I I still not
clear the purpose of providing that
information data to employer only part I
heard is that that helps employer to do
shopping around I wrong I was I was I it
wasn't intent for chopping around it was
more intent I guess in terms of why we
have this database you know is is so I'm
I'm still not clear why why there is a
need for the employer to get the data
from the insurance company besides the
fact that like you said earlier that oh
he might use that information to shop
around to get a lesser premium which is
not the case apparently what is the use
of that no he can absolutely use that
for that purpose yeah he can use but see
sometimes I I guess we try to pass bill
or try to discuss bill that is not even
necessary I I mean I like I said I'm
still having hard to understanding the
need of providing that information to to
employ identify what their needs for
that colletive group are so that they're
not over insuring
themselves that's one of the many
reasons again well terms of what type of
policy they're getting and what is it
are they in the right category over what
they're getting all right because
there're Rises so they're they're it's a
free game what who they can chop around
and what they're going to do who's in
who's out what the deductibles what the
co-pays normally you know when you when
you take the um the the small group
Market you know the only real issue is
age banding you know and your employer
can say you know say well if I if my
employees I'm starting to age up you
know I'm going to be looking for a
different policy than if I had you know
if I had mostly younger employees so and
you know in terms of it it gives them
some you know but it's General these are
Big you know General numbers not
specific to your actual case okay so it
to help them to figure out out what
policy suits which is more but which is
the right policy to get exactly that's
what I mean by shopping
around okay feel better a little bit
Yeah okay good okay so if the if we'll
have an amendment for when we take this
bill up tomorrow
morning and uh um so I guess you would
want to go and have this amendment drawn
up right now so I can get over to ol
it's easy to do Mr chairman
okay and simply now now this this is
basically enabling legislation so the
department can Implement a new program
uh that is Catching Fire Across the
Nation and uh uh but it will be
dependent upon uh that that money
Pennies from
Heaven okay and everybody all right with
that we'll be praying okay this is we
can't vote on because we don't have an
amendment to vote on uh but so that's
that's where we're at so as as a straw
vote are we all okay with it okay all
right
more
uh I thought I I thought I had the all
okay
um
minut
e
okay so um this is
uh
good okay um so obviously this is a much
lighter form than the original bill uh
the concept was that that uh if there is
an
underlying uh loan Behind these these
settlements that uh there is a
responsibility for the uh the judge to
be informed of the issue and then the
judge can make a decision whether they
share that information or not with the
uh opposing
party
okay so we have someone from when you
come on up have a seat turn mic on and
just tell us where you want us to fix it
and we'll fix
it
Anthony yeah there you go chairman my
name is Anthony skolen brini I'm a
lawyer in Nashua uh there are a couple
things I wanted to point out uh the
first thing is and I know this doesn't
really matter but sometimes in
legislative interpretation it does for
the court the title is New Hampshire
third party litigation funding
transparency act this is not really
transparency because it only applies to
one side the vast majority of civil
cases are defended by a third party an
insurance company and there's no
disclosure requirements here for
insurance companies so to the extent
that this is about transparency funding
it should be two-sided not one-sided so
what title would you like um I will tell
you right now that I think that these
this I'm speaking personally yes these
these litigation funding people it
should be illegal period full stop they
should not have them at all okay I'll
tell you a story you want to hear a
story okay I'm happy to hear any story
this I I said this this is a short story
so I've been doing this for a very long
time and I was here when we had
viatical
viatical do you know what a viatical is
it sounds like a medication sir yeah it
does you sell your life insurance policy
and the reason we were regulating it was
this was goes all the way back to to
AIDS and there were a lot of AIDS people
who were given terminal notices and they
were selling their
policies sure I okay yeah so to say that
this is payday loaning you know lending
you know doing where all the you know as
far as I'm concerned is that um I've
never ceases to amaze to me how people
monetize their lives what what they're
going to end up doing and and so this I
and and the argument back then was you
know for a patient that they could use
the money to resolve issues that they
were having before they died and so why
shouldn't they get the money all right I
understand so so before you you know I'm
just qualifying that for you when you go
forward be careful when you say that
because that um and the reason why
um I my wife made the comment as that we
don't want the the person who who has
been harmed you know that that that that
once again they're being harmed again
you know in terms of you know we want to
make sure that that that you know if
because this is available this has
happened we don't want them to feel that
once again the state is you know taking
advantage you know of the of the person
so oh I totally agree okay that's why I
said personally I I don't think I'd have
enough certain well then keep the
personal stuff out there yeah okay okay
that's right all right so I'm always I'm
I'm usually I'm a big U have a problem
with the section ones which is the
purpose and
findings um so is in there really to
this is how disclosure funding
company
so third party you know that's what it
is it's a third party litigation I mean
we just don't have enough of this in the
state to make a real like it's not a big
deal yet maybe it will
be it's seemingly is well because we we
have a problem with our nonprofits now
you know getting getting insurance you
know and so yeah this this issue is out
there I I I that's a different issue but
I will say that like from my perspective
this has really only cropped up recently
with the YDC settlement claims yes and
that's primarily where all of this is
coming from but like I think that you
know that's a fund that has a Sunset and
when that's gone I don't see why it
would not revert back to normal I I
think that there's a lot of people that
are carpet bagging into New Hampshire to
take advantage of the settlement fund
and these people are one of them and and
um
I at the end of the day the idea here is
you know we're not putting this to the
Secretary of State's office like you're
original right this is to the judge and
the judge can make a decision on the
appropriateness of you know the
situation that's that's one thing I want
to make sure um okay it does say all
parties so accept as otherwise
stipulated by order of the Court a claim
it a claim it shall where are you tell
me where you are I'm sorry this is uh
page three line 22 23 and 24 without
waiting all parties inde pending action
so what what Roman numeral you one or
line the line number 22 23 22 except is
otherwise
typ it seems like it it does not apply
to just the court without waiting a
discovery all parties in
appending the time
okay
hasn't okay so if if it went to the
court and was subject to incam review it
might be a little different I I think
that that would be I mean having done
hundreds of pieces of in camera in
camera review litigation I cannot ever
see a judge saying that this would be
relevant for anything I mean it just
doesn't have any bearing on the case in
the same way that plan law I'll stop
saying that plainist lawyers are
precluded from saying that this person
is actually an insurance company the
litigation financing has no bearing on
the facts of the law um so here's
another point that I want to make okay
uh same page lines 10 through 12
paragraph two
okay and then the the next one paragraph
three this imposes a lot of rules on the
attorney client relationship that I feel
are really invasive and so let me give
you an example there are often times
when we have rare cases uh for example
in in New Hampshire 1983 litigation is
relatively rare and in other states
because they have larger populations the
number of cases is much larger and often
times you want to do for your client is
to give them essentially like a real
estate comp and say these things usually
result in this kind of finding and we've
normalized it and based this judgment on
a statistically valid sample of cases
from other jurisdictions sometimes
that's really hard to do like the rarer
the case the rarer the kind of
litigation the more difficult it is to
find that information so which specific
part so that's what I'm saying the
litigation uh the commercial litigation
financer should not make any decisions
have any influence or any direct or
direct decisions I'm I could imagine a
scenario where somebody who's good at
this would have that database and I
would ask them and the law precludes
them from having any influence it might
it might be something that my client
needs to have to make a decision and
there aren't enough lawyers in New
Hampshire that do this kind of work to
give them a relevant sample size of
similar cases that were settled or
resulted in verdicts of trial so I think
that this is one of those things it's
just too invasive and then the last
sentence of paragraph three there is no
reason to state that that is the default
and so this is sort of again making a
problem out of something that's not
actually a problem you have an ethical
obligation of the rules of professional
conduct to do this anyway and there's
nothing that the litigation funding
source could do to change your ethical
obligations uh there's no amount of
money that's worth my borrow license
because my borrow license is how I make
money in the future so like it just
doesn't matter okay right so we're we're
talking about the right to make all
decisions regarding a legal claim
remains solely with the claimant and the
claimant attorney or Law Firm correct
which is stating the obvious it's
stating the obvious but it's also
important to remember that this idea is
mandated in the rules of professional
conduct and so if there is something
that would come in Conflict to the rules
of professional conduct right then I
think it's incumbent to figure out how
it would do so in you know as many cases
as we could foresee here I think like we
don't need to State this I think that
this
particular paragraph is especially
invasive and it's trying to Tinker with
something that fundamentally is a really
private relationship but if it rather
than removing the whole paragraph
because I assume the whole paragraph is
not a pu a p p what remember
professional conduct no no just the last
sentence is the problem professional
conduct okay all right so starting in
line
16 the last sentence uh
the right to make all decisions yeah you
I think got that
Christian okay we'll stke that and then
the the other one in in the same
paragraph uh 13 have any influence is
such a broad phrase again I can think of
situations in which so where are you now
I'm sorry same paragraph line 13 have
any influence it's the second of the
parenthetical phrases after commercial
litigation commercial litigation
financiers shall not make any
decision or have any or direct any
decisions with respect to the court or
legal claim including decisions
appointment or C Council choyer use of
expert Witnesses litigation strategy and
settlement or other resolutions so like
let me give you a very simple example
and we don't deal with this again
because I don't take cases with
litigation financing but there are
instances in which I I want to have my
client have a structured settlement and
oftentimes the structured settlement
people will provide advice here that I
could see a commercial litigation
financer also providing and I would not
want to preclude my client from having
the option of having settlement advice
from somebody who does it professionally
in the same way that I would not want to
preclude my ability to access these
people's information in a way that might
have any influence because that's a
really broad phrase and how I advise my
client when when you don't when you have
a very small state like New Hampshire
with a
relatively commodious civil bar there
often times are not enough publicly
available settlements or verdicts to
advise clients and some of these groups
that do this are National groups that
could have large databases that could
give my clients insights that I as a
lawyer would not have access to and by
having the phrase any influence and then
the last one so 15 the choice or use of
expert Witnesses litigation strategies
or settlements I could imagine somebody
that's a good finan uh commercial
Finance litigation Finance here having
all of those connections and saying to
me Tony I know a person that does this
very rare form of expertise do you want
me to connect you to that person and
under this law that's illegal even
though I would not be able to find that
resource myself and so I would not want
the statute and the legislature to enter
into the attorney client relationship on
of course and then the the final thing
and this is the I'm sorry yeah I'm just
trying to so it shall not make any
decision
um
changing in appointing or changing
Council well that's really weird
huh I mean what if say you what happens
if you have somebody who doesn't know
what they're doing and the commercial
litigation financier says something to
them in a meeting with the client like
did you file this motion and Limon and
the lawyer is like o I didn't is that
violating this statute and I think it
probably is based on the the wording
here because if there's any influence in
changing Council pointing out to
somebody you missed this filing deadline
right that might be something the
commercial litigation financer doesn't
want to have happen because it means the
case gets dismissed and they lose their
money but at the same time it might
functioning the client's best interest I
think this phrase this entire paragraph
is simply too invasive and it is not
precise enough to deal with the the
complexities of an attorney I'm I'm
tending to agree with you but let's see
what else you you have and then the last
the last point I would make and this is
at uh paragraph uh at lines 22 through
lines 28 and this is again going back to
my point about it not being symmetrical
if we really want to provide cons
consumers with information that protects
them in making decisions in legal cases
I want to know what the reserve amount
is set by the insurance company that's
defending the case I also want to know
what the hourly rate is for insurance
counsel whether they're a captured firm
or somebody that contracts with the
insurance Council because both of those
things will give me information that I
could use to advise my client about well
you know what the reserve that they have
for litigation is $112,000 he's going to
settle tomorrow because my guess is he's
at his limit so like if we're really
going to pull this apart then I want it
to be symmetric because it's the only
way to keep consumers informed I I I we
want them to have the best or you know
they're giving up a big S part of their
settlement sure that we want them to
make sure they have the best counsel so
I think that the disclosure should go go
both ways not just with the planets what
is it that you want to see changed in
this paragraph I'm sorry I think it
should be that any third party whether
they're indemnified or not okay should
have to make these disclosures in
including Reserve amounts and the rate
for hour the hourly rate for Council
retained they'll never agree to do
that well I would just want to point out
the fact that this is completely
one-sided and if we ask them to do what
this law is asking plaintiff lawyers to
do they will never agree to it because
it is supposed to be one-sided but if
you want to if you want to change the
language to make it like you want to
make it fair yeah make you want to have
them both pointing guns at each other
let's do it make them maybe we'll scare
them away so they won't do us okay I'm
happy to do that okay so what what what
what words do you want me to change here
so if we had any commercial financing
agreement and then a SE separate
sentence that would essentially say
indemnified parties are under similar
obligations including the disclosure of
Reserve amounts that's a really big
legal phrase for
me you're you're adding a new sentence
into it sure right y okay um you have a
piece of paper and you want to write
okay okay do you understand what he's
doing he's
saying and do you have a is it is it is
it fair that we have both sides and be
equal in this you you should probably
sit up here with a mic okay this is how
I like to doing things I want to have
left and right I like both
sides and I and I noticed that Lindsay
and George left so I didn't see you over
there um so for the record I'm cam La
Pine I work at Orin Reno with George and
Lindsay we represent the New Hampshire
Association of domestic insurance
companies and the American Property
casual Insurance
Association right okay
that that was a whole lot that was just
said um okay so do you have are you
overly offended by us moving that Roman
numeral 3 section and we haven't agreed
to it yet but sure so there is the right
to make all decisions there is a there
are cases there's one case in particular
that I have in my head right now
involving Cisco the big food supplier
company
um a they were involved in a litigation
that involved third party litigation
financing from berford Capital which is
one of the largest funds that
participate in tplf Cisco wanted to
settle the case they wanted to end the
case right berford would not allow them
to do that because of their contractual
obligation for the funding um
so in it's an extreme example but there
are situations where t uh third party
litigation financing companies are
exerting influence on cases and we don't
want that to happen so I think removing
that sentence would would be a problem
be a problem would be a problem yes can
I ask a question to Cameron yeah in that
case what did the lawyer do because I
think that that's probably I mean I I
don't know the the details of that but
just in that factual scenario someone
else someone who's actually probably
unethical if if the client says they
want to settle as a lawyer you can't I
mean ethically you can't you can
withdraw from the case but you can't
resist in order to settle I mean they
have the they have an ethical right to
control the goals of litigation so what
happened so uh Nathan fennessy represent
AIG I'm an attorney at predy flarity uh
so what happened in that case was the
thirdparty finance Year got itself
substituted into the litigation and took
Cisco's place and so they became the
party in interest and took complete
control of litigation so again that's a
a situation that is uh is
isied or were they third party or they
financiers they took they were the
finance year and then took over their
position in litigation I I want to ask
you a specific question again were they
indemnified because that's a difference
right if they're indemnified they're
allowed to do that because they become
the client but then they're not
litigation financiers at that
point I don't know specifically but I'm
I'm telling you that the third party
Finance year took over the litigation
from the the awk don't you think that's
kind of awkward that seems a little
awkward to me I I think that like you
what you want to say you have
some U yeah pull mic so just just to
answer your question about the specifics
of the case it was in the United States
District Court District of Minnesota in
regards pork an
this goes to my joke about how you ask
opinions okay so Jim you have a an
opinion on this who now in this case are
you representing I'm representing State
Farm and I'm always insur State Farm
nobody
else okay even though you work for a law
firm yeah yeah a lot of us do in here
um uh so um with respect to
I mean we're losing the forest for the
trees here because in article three line
13 in page three we're really trying to
get at is making sure that a third party
doesn't control a litigation and the
lawyer is in charge of advising his
clients but in the context of a lawyer
performing their ethical duties by have
Frank conversations okay you don't want
a third party calling the shot
so I personally don't object to the
removing the words have an influence
because if that third party is in the
room the lawyer can do his job he can
tell his clients I think he's wrong but
we're really trying to do here is
prevent one of these litigation finances
from sitting in the room saying you need
to take that settlement and that can be
coercive against the law firm that is
actually um has taken out the litigation
financing so the other stuff um so
you're saying don't remove this
paragraph no I'm not saying don't remove
the whole paragraph but sure take out
the words have any influence because
frankly well how else you change that
sentence because otherwise you're going
to make it from a sh to a
May shall the commercial ler shall not
make any decision any decision or direct
any decision right so you're you're
basically saying you don't have the
right to control to a third party funer
yeah they can still participate and they
can provide all the information that uh
this attorney wants I'm sorry I
forgotten your
name don't Anthony skull breing I the
other thing you could do is simply have
this paragraph say the attorney retains
the right of final refusal on any
proposals made by commercial litigation
financing and then it doesn't matter it
matches and Accords with the rules of
professional conduct Jim's concern is
say that again yeah say that again
simply state that the attorney retains
the right of final decision making on
all aspects of the case that's new
language right that's not here now no no
that would be it and you wouldn't have
to have this long complicated list
talking about what they can't do but
just say lawyer gets to make these
decisions don't don't this doesn't
period the attorney retains the right of
final decision- making on all aspects of
the case and consultation with the
client and that that just means that the
rules of Ethics apply as they normally
apply and the consumer the commercial
litigation financer can't override
anybody but at the same time if they
want to collaborate and it's good for
the client and the lawyer approves it
they can still do that but by having
this language that has all of these
specific things that say you can't do
that you're making it really invasive
instead of saying what we wanted to say
which is the lawyer and the client still
retain all of the decision- making in
the
case yeah so Place paragraph with that
sentence so if you look at article three
here okay right what this is intended to
do is to say to commercial litigation
financers you cannot control this right
okay so if you're an attorney who wants
to
retain the final decision I don't see
what's objectionable about having a law
that says you third party funer
cannot direct the decision so I I don't
see what I have in mind as being
inconsistent with well the question is
is that the third part is allowed to
have an opinion right U Express a point
of view right but that at the uh but
that that ultimately the the final
decision has to be made by the the
attorney and like I I don't think like
in principle Jim's idea of how the law
would work and my idea of how the law
would work irrespective of language
would result in any different outcome
the concern that I have is that by
making the law so narrow and prescribed
it makes it very invasive in a
relationship that is complex already so
I guess there is a point and I'm talk to
you Brian because you're you sponsor
that if if if we were trying to say
what're what we're really care about now
is to make sure that that that this loan
is exists and and it's out there okay do
we really care about the details of that
relationship between those people I mean
do we really need this stuff in here if
we were just to keep it simple to say is
the most important thing that we want to
know is that yes this lawsuit ex you
know this this uh deals exists and let's
just get rid get rid of this because
don't this room's not big enough for
anym lawyers
right just get rid of this this kind of
stuff which is re you know identifying
and I understand what you were trying to
do but it is more than what we really
you I I feel like we were trying to you
know resolve the issue with which was
just that it we just don't want third
parties influencing lawsuits we don't
want them stirring them towards
litigation or stirring him towards other
things or other avenues of things that
are going to cost I understand you don't
want that but at the end of the day what
we're trying to do right of the get-go
was that we at least want to make sure
that the fact that there is that loan
out there and that they're you know like
when say well who's this guy why is he
in this room okay well he represents
them but in terms of why would we want
to go into the statute go into the
detail about what he can or can't do um
you know the judge can be make that
decision whether you think something's
inappropriate going on but that but all
we care about was that yes that that
that
how do how do people feel feel about
that does that make sense so maybe we
can get rid of some of this crap the the
one thing I wanted to point out about
the example with the substituted
litigation Finance here antitrust law is
very different than anything else in the
law it is a subsp specialty that is very
rare those practitioners only do that
kind of work it has to go to federal
court and I've talked to federal judges
when I was doing cles and they are they
are aware of how unique and different
that is than everything else so to pull
an example from antitrust law in
Minnesota in the federal district court
to as a a reason to justify this level
of invasiveness in the attorney client
relationship in really basic simple
straightforward civil cases in the state
of New Hampshire is like basically
saying that we need to change the way a
saddle is made because there might be a
unicorn out there this is not the
reality that most people deal with
antitrust laws are very very different
right if if if we
just if we just got rid of paragraph six
language can we can we just get this
over with
today Roman numeral well it's 294 line
six 294 F3 prohibitions related to
commercial litigation funding on page
three okay just get rid of
that whole
section can that just make your day and
this that that that lines 5 through 20
so it'll be lines five
through 20 is
correct because we're we are not
qualified to be be doing this
conversation this is judiciary and so so
I just you know and I'm I'm a big
believer kiss can I make one pitch for
the reason why you would want to keep
that yes so okay I'm going to I am an
attorney I do practice um I don't just
hang out with you guys up here as fun as
it is um so the reason why you would
want to keep that language is is it's
really informing the client it's not for
the attorney the client is ultimately
the one that's the decider that makes
the decision whether or not to settle a
case and I think in a lot of these
situations you're you know particularly
in I'm
thinking a scenario where they are going
to feel pressure both from the attorney
and from the third-party Finance year to
go in whatever Direction and by putting
this into law you're giving them some
information about what the what control
they have and the the manner of
influence that's
inappropriate um in that
relationship uh well they should make
the decision before they take the loan
in the first
place then you should you know you're if
you're taking this loan you're doing
business with these people you got to
know you know what their motives are and
if you you know if you if you once to me
you're selling your soul to this company
yes and so that I mean you know the fact
that you've made that decision I I I to
then say okay now we're going to say you
know what you can or can't do to your to
the devil
I guess I would just I would just say
the circumstances under which you enter
into like a commercial litigation
financing tend to be sort of these like
bet the company type pieces of
litigation where you really you may not
have much of a choice this is the only
way that you can sort of proceed with
something to keep your operation going I
sure hope their attorney who they had
with them before they signed up told
them
that the other thing I want to point out
is having this in the law does not mean
that the consumers will understand it
any more than Banning murder in the law
means that murders will go away so like
I hear the logic it just it's not how
the real world works the people who are
in these situations are trying to figure
out how to pay their bills and they're
not going to go to RSA 294 F3 and be
like now that I've read the statute and
I'm in this huge Jam I think I want to
tweak these things this stuff is simply
required by the rules of Ethics all of
the concerns that have been raised here
are things that that competent lawyers
have to deal with every day and not just
the rules of Ethics I would add but the
rules of automatic Discovery and
disclosure Superior Court rule
22 our T system has existed for hundreds
of years there almost nothing new Under
the Sun that our courts can't interpret
in
cont I mean I understand you know we we
we all know who the devil is here right
the company that's that's uh seemingly
taking advantage of of
the of the plaintiff and um but I I I I
guess I had made the decision before
last week or whatever I said I said I
just want to narrow this down to get
it's let let every you know let
everybody understand know that this this
exists and but in terms of trying to
educate people or how to how to set
rules in this um yeah this is way over
my pay grade in terms of legal Lee so
uh and and it's going to another
committee
right so so I don't know where it might
know no no no no no keep telling
everybody fiscal note means not where it
goes or who anything knew the fiscal
note means that when the bill was drawn
up that the um the drafter based on the
rsas sent it to some Department who
might care about
it that's where a fiscal note comes from
so it has nothing to do with where the
bill goes to a second committee but did
did this bill this bill never had any
right oh the secretary States was into
it okay all right but that's already
long gone right with this par okay yeah
um
what I'm playing with playing with the
concept if we just
remove um 294 F colon 3 prohibitions
funding no no we made the whole thing
that so F4 is stays there right because
you don't have any problem with
F4 well the note you have here is that
it's not symmetric to make
it by by asserting by inserting after uh
on on line 25 on page three after the
the phrase executed or amended uh
insurance companies shall be required to
make similar disclosures including
Reserve amount litigation budget and the
hourly rate of retained counsel and that
way everybody's playing Fair both sides
have to make
disclosures so you want the insurance
company what did you said so the
insurance company and indemnifies the
defendant they step in and control the
litigation in a in in a much more
intrusive way to be candid than the
commercial litigation Finance here they
can do everything because of an
Indemnity agreement and since we're
treating these outside third parties uh
for protection of consumers in this law
the question is should it only be
one-sided and I don't think it should be
and if we want to make it symmetrical
then the insurance compan I'm totally
confused here sit back um so now we're
saying that the defendant in our case is
the state of New Hampshire no that is
not correct okay the defendant is the
the I thought was the plain the the the
the person who's suing the state because
they've been harmed no the the plaintiff
is the party that does the suing that's
the plaintiff okay okay so in this case
this is let's have Tony come up with an
example of say a slip and fall yeah like
a slip and fall you go to Mark basket
you're picking out bananas right you
slip and fall you sue Market Basket cuz
they didn't put that you know sticky
felt tape down right you are the
plaintiff Market Basket is the defend
defendant okay so it is not it is very
rare for the state to be the defendant
in a case like this okay so dealing with
a defendant yeah okay Market Basket so
Market Basket is a little different
because they're self-insured but if it
was like Haniford they are in they have
outside insurance and so what happens
exactly the outside Insurance steps into
the shoes of the defendant and makes all
the controlling decisions in defending
the case because of an Indemnity
agreement that's part of the insurance
so what I'm saying no no that has
nothing to do with this no no but what
I'm saying is if there is if this is
truly about third-party funding and
litigation then the defendants
thirdparty funding should also be
required to make similar
disclosures they already do so under
Court rule 22 they do not they do not
have to disclose their Reserve amount
they do not have to disclose their
litigation budget they do not have to
disclose the hourly rate for defense
cwhere I did all right we'll just put
all right we'll put
that right now yeah how do you guys you
obviously feel different about this
right no we feel the same and we just no
I'm saying feel right yeah we feel
different from Tony I it just feels like
we're
we're the issue here was not about
insurance companies the issue was about
someone who was
financing the settlement
okay but that's not what the the title
of the bill is the title of the bill is
litigation funding
transparency
correct litigation funding and insurance
companies are funding the
defense how about uh third party um
settlement
funding you know I'm fine but you know
and what I'll tell you what I feel like
we're we're we're it's good to get rid
of that Pro rition thing this issue here
take it up with the Senate sure take it
up with the Senate but I no I don't
think we need to get into that because
we're not that's not what this was Bill
about this bill is not about you know
that the fact that that Market Basket
said okay you insurance company if this
is your case now you're walking away
from it no no that's that's not I don't
see
that it doesn't make sense it doesn't
make sense to participate this think
about it and that is okay it if I'm in a
car accident okay and and whether I'm at
fault you know in terms of yes my
my it's a big lawsuit around it okay um
so I you know I have um uh you know I
have maximum coverages okay and I have a
an
umbrella right so what I'm saying is
that yes but at that point my umbrella
is running the case because they're
defending me
all right they're the ones who don't
want to make a big settlement so what
what disclosure do I have to do I need
to I think we had this was like the bill
we had last year where was he were
supposed to disclose exactly so that at
this point I I do say um I understand
where you're now coming from and no I
don't agree I think I voted the the
wrong way on that issue for you okay so
at this point I I think I think that's
not necessary I really don't that's not
what this I I understand that you think
it should be a fair and equal thing I'm
always in favor of fair and equal we're
not that's different right just like we
change the title no I
don't we don't need to change the text
okay we're gonna just at this point I'm
R is there anything else we need to
anything else other than that I think
we're you you beat this horse beat this
horse
Okay okay so now we want to talk to the
subcommittee because we want to see
whether
La okay
lawyers go back to your corner go back
to your corner now you're the lawyer
say and
right you don't have standing when it
come okay is it more about Investors out
their investors pitching in so the
investor dependent yeah they're pitching
in but that what the whole issue with
that what that was going on was is how
much of a role because you are investing
it how much is a role you have and how
the case is being run and operated and
you know and to me they're the devil
okay this you know the idea that you're
going to go out and have somebody pay
you know give you money up front you
know based on the case it's it's a
little I think sideline but I think the
it's that's we you know predatory you
know it's predatory it's it's icky you
see cases are very good example that's a
lot of money involved that's a lot right
well and the fact that they're slammed
on slammed on cases but didn't they lose
one of the cases just the the the uh
State one I guess but okay so I just
want is everybody comfortable okay so if
every that's when it begin right now
where I think I am and I think we are is
just removing uh
df3 prohibitions related to commercial
litigation funding so we're just moving
that section of the
bill
removing
F4 F4 I I don't think we need to mess
around with F4 it's
fine it's just
F3 so basically you're allowing you're
allowing a third party Financial or
outside investor to pitch in the money
to run the cas at this point we're not
getting into what's the nature of that
relationship or they're doing in the
case or how they mck M things around
what we're just trying to do is get
everybody aware that it's it exists
we're not saying you can't do it we just
want to know that you're doing it and
and and as the the lawyer was pointing
out that most of these things actually
there is case law that you can't do it
and they're rules okay so they're legal
rules okay okay so at this point um uh
we we can I mean technically we don't
have a correct Amendment so normally I
wouldn't have his vote but so I would
say is a straw vote are we are we the
straw vote are we um okay with this
amendment
0631 um less uh par section 294
F3
it it's a Nuance that he was trying to
get into in terms of the of the lawyer
you about if the insurance company okay
because remember what's driving this
legislation is insurance companies are
are pointing out that they they play an
important role in settlements and so yes
we respect his opinion that that he's
know because that's who's usually on the
other side of cases that they're dealing
with but that's not what this legis you
know he can he has a great argument to
go to the Senate and say this is not
fair it's unequal but at the same time I
would say is all we did is is had put
something in that is disclosing that
everybody now knows it that that
exists
okay you all right with
that okay so the straw booat is um uh
accept this amendment 63 G1 uh less uh
section F3 and that just so for minua
that when you see this bill tomorrow it
just it all the things will get after
then so in other words the F4 will now
become F3 they just they just move
things we're executing that tomorrow
okay okay um I I will take care of
getting it
done okay um all those in
favor all right
okay
here okay yes
seven
can okay
if you're going to remove that 294 F3
there are some definitions that are no
longer needed um like all of the
definitions uh beginning on L page two
line 23 that is all about the for an
entity of concern which I if you're
needed because there's a reference to
forign entity of concern oh I like so
294 F3 which you you just to remove
right right okay no but where where
which definition don't you like oh sure
oh well it's not that I don't like it
it's that which one it doesn't need page
two line 23 P two through Page Three
line four is no longer necessary wait a
minut no okay I'm on page
one and my page two definition Okay so
which definition you starting with so
page two line 23 23 Roman 5 foreign
country or person of concern you've
removed the section of the bill that
yep and what else what else did you say
so it would be page two line 23 through
Page Three line four is no longer
necessary for all the foreign entity
language
yep was only in that
paragraph yeah it only appeared on page
three line
removed find Which Way what what are you
saying we what you want were upt to
leave it and then we would just take out
so if I go go back to Rum number one a
commercial litigation finan shall not
enter any commercial litigation
financing agreement directly or
indirectly with a foreign entity of
concern or foreign country or person oh
okay so that means we we will leave F3
defition okay okay so now by not having
to mess around down with
definitions now the only thing we're
what we're going to
remove is no no no no no we're we're
just now we've just shortened how much
we're moving so now we're going where he
says 294 F3 where we prohibition related
to commercial litigation funding we're
saying um it we're leaving in Roman
numeral
one but we're deleting two three and
four so lines 10 through 20 on page
three will be deleted
okay you don't care now you don't shake
yes nice try you know in retail we say
times okay so all right so delete
roll
two three and
four you don't have no ex yeah no
same leave the definitions because we
don't want we don't want Foreigner
foreigners those Chinese companies
Chinese over that's a good thing we ban
you know large po we're large percentage
of the world's
there I know you will pull out the on
side
yeah well what happened is if it if it
if it was originally designed supposed
to go to finance okay the other
bill the insurance the insurance bill oh
the paint Bill
yes the funding
mechanism that means they it was it was
probably going to go to finance and and
Ken wer will moved not to to wave that
means it has to go on the
consent it can't go on the consent wait
at this point at this point we would
leave it on the regular calendar
look yeah it's a voice if nobody signs
up if nobody signs up it's a voice V
no I don't good enough figure out what
the heck is
going okay all right so is everybody
understand the agreement that we're
we're going to um uh just remove
four that's
tomorrow okay all right all right we're
right
e